dutchy is the highest flying software
company in the cannabis industry it has
a 3.8 billion dollar valuation there's
no company in the space that sells
software that has a valuation even close
to it and what duchy does is very simple
they help dispensaries put their menus
online so consumers can order a joint or
a vaporizer or a pack of edibles and
then
go to the dispensary and pick it up they
also sell point of sale software which
is basically a cash register for
dispensaries
duchy was founded by two brothers who
were born in michigan zack and ross
lipson both were entrepreneurs before
and this is not their first company
previous to duchy had background in
online food ordering and four years ago
i was about 30 years old living in bend
oregon which is where we're
headquartered now and cannabis went
legal and i was a cannabis consumer
myself passionate about the industry and
the opportunity ahead was in a
dispensary that first day of
legalization and when standing in a very
long line out the door around the corner
the light bulb went off in my head which
was online ordering for the cannabis
space and i remember thinking with my
background in online food ordering being
in oregon one of the first states to
legalize that was the right person to
take that task on so i quickly called my
brother here shared with him the idea
and it was a really quick
flip of a switch we looked at each other
and said we have to do this we were both
working on tech startups you know
throughout our entire career both
spanning about a decade ross was always
on the business and sales side and i was
always focused on kind of the other half
of the business which is product so it
kind of was sort of this like perfect
opportunity you know for us to bring
both of those strengths together and to
build something really compelling
duchy solves a few problems for
dispensaries they help dispensaries
track inventory report automatically to
state agencies to make sure these
dispensaries are in compliance and also
act as the cash register for the
dispensary
they are not however a payment processor
so there are other companies that
actually process the payments and across
the industry really cash is king most
transactions are done in cash the way
the cannabis space and has kind of
evolved from a regulatory standpoint
there's there's much stricter
restrictions on these businesses so they
really need help um and the best place
for them to turn is to technology right
technology can kind of automate that
process for them
what drew me to dutchy is frankly it's
valuation it's an outsized valuation 3.8
billion dollars they're a private
company and you know when you put them
in context of publicly traded cannabis
companies you'll see that over the last
year their values have dropped at least
50 percent
whereas duchy's valuation has increased
120 percent
there's a really compelling reason why
big name investors from howard schultz
the billionaire former ceo of starbucks
to
the nba star kevin durant to
big funds like tiger global which is
back jewel spotify peloton other really
big promising companies so what these
companies see in duchy is in a word
potential so
duchy is a vehicle for these investors
to invest in the cannabis industry
without backing a company that touches a
federally illegal drug
[Music]
duchy is an opportunity for people to
get in on the cannabis industry while
it's still in its infancy in 2021
u.s cannabis sales were at 25 billion
dollars by 2030 that's supposed to grow
to 100 billion so really what duchy is
is a vehicle for people to get on the
ground floor of one of the fastest
growing industries in america our
mission here is to create safe and easy
access for cannabis and anything that
propels the industry forward and
normalizes it helps professionalize it
we believe is a positive we really
believe genuinely that cannabis brings a
strong positive societal change and
effect to the entire world
duchy claims 41 market share and they
say they process 12 billion dollars in
transactions a year
you know that is definitely the most
rosy picture possible when you speak to
other investors in the space there's a
lot of skepticism around that number and
then when you dig down a little further
you know they are not a payment
processor so they're not technically
processing these payments like you know
visa or square would if they were in the
space but you know big picture wise most
of the transactions are done in cash for
most of these transactions there is not
a payment processor you know processing
a transaction through
a credit card or a debit card
one of the things that we've always
prioritized as a business is making sure
that we're built in a way where we can
scale with our customers we know that
this is a fast growing industry and
these businesses are aspirational when
we talk to customers they're talking
about how many more locations they're
going to open next year so we've
designed this business to be able to
scale up and what that means is we have
support teams and we have customer
success teams that are dedicated to
making sure that these dispensaries
these retailers have what they need when
they start to grow that
was a huge benefit for us when all of a
sudden we got this influx of new
business through covid quickly we were
seeing these dispensaries who weren't
relying on online ordering some didn't
even have it yet we're reaching out to
us and saying we need to get up and
running quickly and we were able to turn
that product around very very fast and
provide a solution to them and it
literally carried them through the
pandemic what duchy has been able to do
is to sell their software cheaper than
their competitors and they want to be in
as many doors as possible and they're
doing a pretty good job getting the
country's biggest dispensaries and the
country's smallest dispensaries on board
so right now their main goal is growth
one would think ending the federal
government's prohibition on marijuana
would be a good thing for all companies
in the marijuana industry it is true it
obviously will be good for most
companies but
there is an argument that duchy is in a
very good place right now once cannabis
is legalized federally duchy is going to
have a lot of competition from companies
like visa square and shopify
[Music]